introducing first with a record Oh one
win three defeats representing of the
real rejects channel on YouTube and did
you break the TV that's all I care about
it might have been worth it if it did
that would have been worse that's gonna
be slow-motion that's gonna be means
that might be the highlight of their
night it might be if that is their
highlight as that was impressed that's
all the answer
hello reject nation I'm Greg Alva I'm
Andrew
so we're gonna review the defenders
today full-on series of
stream-of-consciousness thoughts boilers
small errors and everything there and
yeah through a go check out the Schmoe
down match the John and I were on if you
haven't seen it yet I threw in my kick
part because I was sick by the way how
much did it cost to get a stunt man to
do to play you for that little bit this
time I was like five hundred dollars but
digitally CGI my face on his cost
thousand dude now I see where James
Cameron got that inspiration NATO 42 the
3d for redoing Arnold's face and that's
like with the stunt guy sediment early
now I see dude that was incredible yeah
inspired like a new generation of
filmmakers I inspired the whole 3d we
release it's good I'm glad I finally got
to see the leaders anyway let's let's
hop onto the defenders review so but you
know what I've got done you know most of
the I've covered all the episodes
essentially with quick thoughts on each
episode and I and the last one I gave my
general consensus saying that this show
was good I didn't find it great just
really quick what was what was your
overall thoughts on it alright so I've
seen this show twice Sam Weiss yes so
the first time I saw it I did enjoy it
I did feel there was you know some
things I had problems with here and
there like some tonal inconsistencies
the way of Sigourney Weaver's character
Alexandra the way she's off the way our
electric hills are off I had a little
bit of an issue which I'll get to in
this so I mean but a couple of things
that I had other issues with seeing it a
second time I actually because I'm
looking for these things now and I know
what to expect
I found myself enjoying this show a lot
more the second time around I can see
that I cut them with you I'm not in in a
place where I'm it's like daredevil
seasons 1 & 2 and I'm like this is
outstanding and incredible but I'm kind
of but I'm not in a place to say it's
it's just okay I'm kind of more in the
middle like good legal matter than Iron
Fist yeah what I loved about this show
too is the character interactions the
human depth and emotion like we are so
invest in these characters and obviously
so from their previous shows and but you
made a point live people weren't a big
fan of
of Finn Jones is Danny Rand iron fist so
I thought he did a lot better job in
this the fight choreography while not
fantastic like in daredevil season 1 & 2
our seasons 1 & 2 I did still think they
did a pretty good job there are
definitely moments where the cameras
fascinating CW a little Christopher
Nolan and Batman Begins where it yeah I
think so fast what just happened I can't
really tell what's going on so but there
definitely were moments were some
tracking shots other other moments
during fights were and where you're like
this is really cool and entertaining not
to the level of what you probably would
have wanted but it still did the job
enough to get you a Jane I feel like it
didn't do the job and I want to go into
some pros in a second because I know
when you start off just with the
criticisms people were like you hate
this show but while we're on the subject
of the fights I feel like when it comes
to the fight scenes here the main reason
it bothered me is because there is a
huge backlash with the way the fights
were handled with Iron Fist season 1
after coming off of you know seasons 1 &
2 of daredevil and I thought like well
you have daredevil in here and you're
crossing these people over you should
have like the same level of direction at
least if the choreography is not even
gonna live up to the the caliber of
daredevil then at least have the action
direction of it live up to that caliber
instead of all the crazy cutting and
editing and you know all that because
I'm like well you know Luke Cage and
Jessica Jones they don't have a fighter
they don't really have a fighting style
they're just strong brutes yeah that's
all they are and so I don't expect a lot
from them and a lot of the way daredevil
moved was still really cool it's just
the overall nosov it you know especially
when they're fighting the hand in the
end the last couple episodes I'm like
the hand and I thought these were a
bunch of skilled warriors why are they
all just a bunch of henchmen yeah yeah
there's gonna say - when you said in
regards to martial artists like Danny
Brant got his ass kicked and I don't
mind him getting his ass kicked a little
bit because we want our heroes to feel
some tension in some danger so you know
we feel that but it just it was too much
sometimes yeah I'm glad towards the end
he finally got to really kick some ass
which was good but it just it didn't pay
off the way I personally wanted it to in
regards to iron fist being the best
martial artist in the world I know that
there are a lot of people have cases for
daredevil
being a better martial artist what I
don't even want to get into the argument
of that I just want to say like it just
never you never get the sense that
Daniel Rand is the greatest martial
artists and the with or without his iron
fist true and that's what I want to
thank I call your crew of that as far as
pros go with this show I feel like the
strength of this specific series now and
when I say this I'm not entirely sure my
feelings on it yet are because of the
expectation of seeing a crossover show
or it just lacked whenever the
characters weren't intertwining with
each other but the interactions between
the four main defenders were great and
especially when you break them apart
because every time they interacted
especially by Episode four when they're
hiding out in the restaurant
I loved all that like there's pretty
much no the Royal dragon yeah I think
that's what the episode is called
actually and the entire interaction
there was fantastic amongst the four of
them and then when you even divide it up
I think Danny Rams friend Jones it hears
for hire teasing all that but just
importantly like their relationship
their dynamics those two actors working
together I felt my culture brought out a
better performance of Finn Jones I was I
need time Finn John's is just casually
being Finn Jones and not being honest
it's like I know he's trying to it
started contained anger that wants to
come out but it's like but regardless of
those kind of things their interaction
their chemistry is great when Daredevil
and Jessica Jones are alone with each
other their banter back and forth is
great when they start getting along and
understanding each other and joking
around together that's all really
fantastic so the big strength of this
show and the thing that you want most
from it is really strong here when
they're all together that's when the
series is at its best so you got to give
this show that whether or not you find
the show a disappointment that is all
great when they're all interacting with
each other yeah no I agree with that the
carrot the main strength of this show is
the characters and the character
interactions and again the depth and the
human emotion how invested you get in
these guys in these care
interacting with each other because
again we've already we've if you've
watched the other shows you're already
familiar with these characters and you
should already be invested with that to
some extent but seeing them interact
with each other how is that going to
work and I thought it all really worked
well and plot was it made sense why they
were all working you know working
together so it wasn't like this is kind
of force no it organically ended up
working together but yeah like you said
those are the things that I enjoy the
most are their interactions whenever
they're together whatever they're
fighting together to but when they break
up and and they start doing like two on
twos more when they're when they're
talking like like you said here's for
higher Mike Colter and a rather Luke
Cage and Danny ran those are some of my
favorite scenes in the entire all eight
episodes because like you said Mike
Colter brings out something in Finn's
owns where he's just relaxed he's just
being himself and I know he's playing a
character it's not playing Finn Jones
but he just like you said he's not
trying to be like that child with that
inner anger which hated me he's not
trying to do then I just I appreciate
those scenes more because you get more
into the mind of the character without
oldest over-the-top nonsense but those
are my favorite scenes I like how
they're teasing Heroes for Hire that
that stuff seems very interesting I love
to during the show how they all got an
iron fist like yeah I'm just calling him
ironclad and and then he's making fun of
yeah he's making fun of him for punching
the molten heart of the Dragon it's like
dude I'm just kidding and then I'm I
think one of my favorite quotes in the
entire shows from sticker says the
immortal iron fist is still a thundering
dumb man yeah I love all that stuff and
again the show is written pretty well in
terms of dialogue and character
interactions I thought that was very
strong but like like an OCA start go
ahead we're gonna say what I think I
gotta give this show credit to beyond
the four main defenders interacting I
what I really appreciate about this is
something that the that the show is able
to give us that when you think of like
the Marvel movie crossovers that they
don't really give us so strongly is the
supporting characters get to have a lot
to do in here to beyond the four main
defenders you get a pretty good amount
of Kali you get pretty much calling
winged throughout this whole series and
you get a lot of stick in here you get
Elektra and you get a see foggy and care
like they all get storylines me
the night especially Malcolm the fish
lottery hell yeah they all be they're
all able to get storylines and have
special scenes they're like one of my
favorite like fanservice moments was
when they're in the pre scene and then
you have all the supporting characters
from the supporting like protagonist
characters all in the same hideout room
that was a really big delight because we
were like oh yeah one of these guys
haven't met each other yet even
carrie-anne moss makes an appearance
about Gerry Gerry Hogarth yeah so there
was there's a lot of that that I really
appreciate they want other way to do
more than just blend the four main
defenders we also got to see the
supporting characters that we love as
well but I think what I liked about it
the most was it again
it feels very organic it's not they're
just it's not feeling fully so we're
like why are all these characters in
this room why are they all like meeting
with each other again it felt very
organic I like seeing them on there and
like you said I like that they all had
something to do not asleep cause they're
more hiding in a precinct at some point
but again those interactions just pay
off in a way that I appreciate it and
you know from where they take on the
shows and also I like that they do a lot
of foreshadowing for what we're gonna
see in the future shows with these
characters with the when they're talking
about things like yeah we even see like
one Easter egg I believe was on one of
the buses when with Luke Cage in Episode
one or two you see it says new Harlem
Renaissance that's of course it's really
one of the transitions yeah yeah that's
obviously a foreshadowing to Mariah and
Shades their new business in Harlem so
and then you are also mentioning some
MCU crossover stuff the the stuff I
noticed from you know what they
mentioned about MCU crossovers I noticed
they said they talked about the incident
that's of course the Battle of New York
that happened in the climax of Joss
Whedon's the Avengers in 2012 they also
if you remember in Karen Paige's office
which is Ben Urich sold office that she
took over who of course the whole thing
there yeah yeah there were two articles
there was one of the Battle of New York
and there was also when it said Harlem
brawl on it that's the fight between
Hulk and abomination 2000 dates the The
Incredible Hulk I believe is Louis litt
let er the drink that but that so again
you see the connections there and then
also to I was trying to look and see if
there was an Avengers tower run I
couldn't spine notice it but then if you
remember in spider-man homecoming he did
sell it hopefully yeah so to Oscorp
Norman Osborn I'm hoping but the
question is what specific
timeline is the defenders on when it
comes to yeah it's not yeah but again
it's cool that they make they make a
little bit of a point to mention some MC
you cross never stuff I mean if there's
something this show did well in the end
of it because I have problems with this
ending that I'll get into but it does
set up the solo shows in a good way to
you know like with Iron Fist I was like
that it's official new suit like the
green jumpsuit yeah and yes technically
you can obviously evolve I mean we saw
daredevil [ __ ] fall from the end of
season 1 to season 2 they made it a
storyline how they cracked with the
Helmand they have got kind of a new suit
or the new helmet rather so I mean I'm
hoping that's not it he's got yeah
because we've clearly seen now in this
show he's inspired by by Matthew Murdock
by Matt sacrifice in the end there and
to protect his my city so yeah you know
that and he was inspired a lot by Matt
by how Matt sacrificed himself how much
he cared about saying he understands
that's his duty now that the hand is I
guess technically gone even though we
think that Elektra and Madame Gao are
still alive out there but most of the
hand has been destroyed now so now Danny
rands taken upon self you know to have
that inspiration of being like I'm there
gonna be a vigilante in New York then I
want to see him wear that mask yeah yeah
and it cuz aren't for season 1 did not
give us a vigilante in New York of iron
fist and it also sets up calling wing
and Misty night dragons dollars a dragon
yeah
daughters of the dragon coming together
with her her arm getting cut her
interaction was very interesting to the
when they're talking about and again the
arm being cut off that happens in the in
the comics she gets her arm in an
explosion her arm comes off Tony Stark
actually gives her that binary arm or
that bionic arm rather and I believe
it's got superhuman powers got super
strength superhuman powers and her
soldier yeah very similar actually to
that and so that and now we know in this
calling wing mentioned that Danny Rance
got some connections or rather that he
owns the hospital so he we know that
he's kind of taken the place of Tony
Stark their alien Airport and we got the
origin of call of a rather of misty
night getting her arm like that so that
was really cool I thought plot wise it
made sense and
kind of - they're going on a little bit
of Easter Egg here going on with the
loss of limbs of like Star Wars were in
all the original ones - loses an arm and
Marvel likes to pay trip and then and
then Phase two and you got a rather you
got a Iron Man 3 off vertically and
loses his hand
you got a Winter Soldier and loses his
hand Winter Soldier guardians of the
galaxy nebula loses a Winter Soldier
owner on Civil War he does but I'm
talking about when Arnim Zola replaced
his arm with a vibranium and then yes
Iron Man does smash up when I'm talking
about phase 2 films and then also I
believe in Thor the dark world the film
I'm not very fond of we see Loki pretend
to cut off Thor's hand so again they're
just paying that that loss of limbs loss
of hands paying that in tribute so I
thought that was really cool it's
Nicktoons lost his arm and how he
escapes is just shows the
resourcefulness how much he's a badass
but I think one of the biggest strengths
of this show not the way the character
ends is the villain Alexandra I really
found myself very invested in this
character I thought she was
sophisticated as intellectual she was
she had a presence about her when she
came into a room I felt she was menacing
she took control of that room like and
the other members of the hand even
though they started to question her in
later episodes at the beginning you
could see before she started getting a
week and all how much they did respect
her and have that fear level especially
Madame Gao why do you say that because
it did dawn on me before I shot this
with you like I will go into my issues
with her death after I know you have
some issues with the band - I do and
because when when Sigourney Weaver is
there on screen she is perfect she's
perfectly gasps in this role she is
multi-layered I loved her introduction
it kinda reminds me Wilson Fisk's
introduction Tallulah
in terms of like you see this villain
but she's introduces this very
vulnerable
lonely woman who like at the very top of
her introduction and then as it goes
you're like oh this is kind of a she's
sensitive yeah but she's she's one tough
cookie who's pretty scary - she didn't
and she's able to kick some ass she's
able to kick some ass - she takes on
Elektra when in lectures reborn and also
she cut her some parts of restoring on
remind me a little bit of caught her
mouth yeah she gets killed off before
the season wraps up and at the same time
you know like the fact how cottonmouth
never seem to really be the one who had
a one-up on Luke there were a lot of
Luke Cage it's kind of how I felt with
Alexandra if and fortunate she gets
killed off right when she gets her major
one up on the defenders yeah so yeah I
mean I over all there's plenty to
appreciate and there's plenty I really
like and in terms of other pros to it I
got excited for the daredevil storyline
I know very little about the born-again
storyline but when they say Maggie I was
like oh yeah that's Daredevils mom right
there and we haven't seen Daredevils mom
and anything yet so I'm excited to see
her being clowning Matthew Murdock I've
seen her in anything either that's true
that is true just somewhat coming out of
the vagina just pointing out the obvious
yeah after the radio has when he can see
Matthew has not seen her in a very long
time and with Jessica Jones I felt it
essential that they had to do her in the
beginning of this show dealing with the
repercussions of what happened with
kilgrave and now we don't have to deal
with that in seasons here Jessica Jones
we could just hop onto her next
adventure
baby and yes I I felt like there was
plenty go that there was plenty of good
things though but however there were
there were things that were dead and
there were times I genuinely laughed a
lot I gotta give it that - there were
times I oh yeah yeah the humor was very
organic I said the script the dialogue I
thought many times I wasn't really
cringing or saying that's pretty bad
dialogue I can't believe they said that
like maybe one or two times I might have
said that but overall throughout the
eight episodes I found myself thinking
the humor was very organic very
appropriate
you know they let dramatic moments it
when they needed to they hit moments of
humor and I think some of my favorite
humor moments or between Jessica Jones
and Matt Murdock absolutely I think one
in particular my favorite is when she
sees him with the scarf so like you look
like an [ __ ]
it's your scarf yeah I gotta get that
one up on there but I love those kind of
moments and also to just a little Easter
Egg as well when Matthew Murdock and
Jessica Jones meet in the police station
in the interrogation room it really
mirrors visual imagery wise and also
dialogue wise really mirrors an alias I
believe it's issue number three when
Matthew Murdock does the same thing
comes into the interrogation room the
dialog in the visual imagery like I just
said it's very similar to that so I
thought that was cool they kind of
visually paid homage to that and and
dialogue why so that was going you
pointed out best I love their
interactions together they are so good
together those two they've great humor
cat-and-mouse relationship and when they
finally learn when she like starts
investigating more into him and into his
past like those moments really carry a
lot of weight because she figures out
who this guy really is not behind all
the gimmicks and the and the lawyer
stuff and the daredevil like he's got a
father who was a boxer and he was beaten
up and he was a good guy like it was
some really good marketing like and
that's what I mean by the human depth
and emotion in the show like they really
did in subtle moments they really did a
good job of painting that and making me
feel again reinvested in these
characters in a way I didn't think I
could get you so I just appreciated that
and also to when they're talking to I
was it Lexie I can't remember the little
girl the architects daughter Lexi I
can't remember her name when Matt's
playing the piano and they're looking
for the blueprints if you listen closely
exactly in the Incredible Hulk tune it
is the incredible he was actually was
playing the defenders dude Matthew
Murtagh I tell you when he's honing in
his Beethoven his Mozart he sounds
pretty damn good I would be good I would
watch an entire season of just Matthew
Murdock playing the piano yeah that's
how good it was
but ya know I'm I kind of want to talk
about Alexander for a sec so yeah let's
go into some cons things that when we're
going into cons our show they're gonna
be cons that you find to be cons and
then cons that I find to be constant
we'll probably disagree on some things
but yeah let's let's let's start hopping
into some stuff you can go with the
Alexander so like I said this character
was very sophisticated intellectual she
had that presence I was invested with
her and whenever Sigourney Weaver's on
screen she's very three-dimensional she
just takes over and I'm I'm in but my
issue with her death it's not that she
had a death I had no issue with that
that's not a problem for me at all what
I had an issue with was it happening in
Episode six I would have preferred more
like it towards the end of episode 7
maybe mid way towards Episode eight and
plot wise I would have preferred
something instead of Elektra you know
using the two sides on her and killing
her after she'd given the order to kill
her loved one to kill Matthew The
Devil's of Hell's Kitchen she says his
name is Matthew I got where she was
coming from I understand what they were
going for I just
it would have been more dramatic and
more compelling if like in the
underground tunnel in the in the final
climactic battle yeah
Alexandre has now been rejuvenated she's
got the serum and she's able that she
has her strength and she's able to kick
some of the defenders ass which wouldn't
increase the tension and that seems like
they got Alexandra back damn how are the
defenders supposed to beat them which
will go into all that in a second but I
just think like let's say Alexandra's
got daredevil pinned down she's
literally about to kill him whatever
that's that moment when you see on
electors face is she gonna still serve
the hand and and trust her mentor or is
she gonna do the Darth Vader thing and
save him with the Emperor's you got to
kill Luke and and now she's got a turn
and I know that would have felt a little
similar to return the Jedi you're
already doing similar things to return
the Jedi you got a Luke trying to see
the good in his father Matt's not trying
to see the good in Elektra also you got
some winter vibe Winter Soldier vibes in
there with Bucky and and Steve are
fighting and you know that you got that
that restraint because this is my friend
I'm not gonna fight her this is my loved
one I'm not gonna fight them so I
wouldn't have mind if they would have
done something like that would have made
the death it can feel more dramatic and
compelling damn that is a worthy and
satisfactory death I mean I'm sure
there's many other ways I could have
done I just like I said I was so
invested and I found myself I'm not
gonna say I love this character as much
as Wilson Fisk or the purple man
somewhere right around that range but I
will say I was really invested in this
character to the point of when the death
happened like it's gonna felt like a
throwaway irrelevant character and I
just ya didn't hit me the right way I
wanted it to that mean that was that's
my you see the funny thing is is like
when she died that was a big oh [ __ ]
moment for me and it definitely impacted
me and I thought see my initial reaction
was a little different - her reaction
when she died was Oh clever a lecturers
main villain now this is cool it was
when the next two episodes followed
where I'm like oh it's like Alexandra's
presents never even mattered anymore
yeah it's like you forget about her you
you just completely forget about her
prey even Luke Cage goes out of its way
to remind you of who cottonmouth was
after a cottonmouth dies and here it
just makes the whole the entirety of the
handful even weaker and I was already
feeling like the hand is a pretty weak
villain after all the build-up we've
gotten from you know T's a no boo
Madame galin season one a daredevil then
like half the last half of season two a
daredevil all of iron fist all the
defenders and then the end of the hand
it's like these guys seem easy to defeat
you just never felt the stakes it would
never eat you out like a lot even you
know four of these guys like they were
really threatened to the yeah how are
they gonna defeat and it's like
Terminator 2 or die hard how is Arnold
supposed to repeat the t1000 there it's
and then when you see it happens like
that was that was logic it was
satisfactory in the stakes and the
tension we're at an all-time I never
seem like an impossible villain for them
to defeat and I feel like if you're
gonna cross over all four of the guys
awesome you gotta do it and on top of
that too it's like this is a pretty big
letdown in terms of who the hand is
because the hand has been built up from
so many different shows that this hand
character does this whole organization
should have been more intimidating it's
like what's the Japanese guys named Mero
Kamiya Billy mera kaam me it was so
interesting to me how it was handled
with this guy because his introduction
was badass his team Sigourney Weaver are
great their interactions yeah and then
they're setting him up to me this really
lethal warrior and then almost every
scene is mid slit or not that I get
nothing
yeah like what is the point of this guy
I agree with you the only thing that
would kept me other than the
introduction and that fight scene with
him where he kind of did take control
him was being a badass the thing that
kept me invested with this character as
someone I like found myself like not
rooting for but like he's a pretty
interesting villain where his
interactions with Alexandra because the
way he was challenging her I'm like this
is some good I'd love seeing villains
challenging other villains in the same
organization like this is actually
interesting stuff I like this but again
his is is fine like I just don't feel
threatened whenever he's fighting it out
defenders I want like how are they
supposed to beat this guy never felt
that isn't all the skilled warriors are
all just henchmen that's all they are
yeah and I think my biggest
disappointment was Sawan day when they
showed him beating the [ __ ] out or not
being the crap he was pushing Luke
Adrian is winning the fight yeah I was
like this is sick and then when Luke
Cage bring something like I wanted to
see that fight I wanted to see how Luke
finally was able
like because it didn't look like Luke
was having an easy time in any way was
pushing him around because he was using
the fingers from Kunlun so and I got
that that was all compelling and
interesting but I'm like I want to see
this during my reaction actually like
I'm so happy Luke got him I kind of wish
we saw this though you know hey guys
this isn't us being negative anyway
these are just in our opinion things
that could have made the show what we
personally would have maybe wanted it to
be but again I still found a lot of
great things in this I'm just we're just
going over some things like personally
bothers me I just don't want to feel
like this is totally negative cuz I
thought like 15 20 minutes covering a
lot of positives they made it this far
it is you know what when it comes to the
hand I feel like you were building up
their master plan so much and by the
time you got to the final episode Kalon
is very very lackluster I don't really
feel like you're gonna feel like they
don't have a chance at succeeding and
any time they're fighting them they're
weak and then making a lecturer the main
villain was a clever thing I guess on
paper but by the time it did happen the
fact that she doesn't even give a [ __ ]
about the hand makes the hand just look
even weaker in general and then I'm like
I don't really care enough for them to
take down Elektra and I don't really
find the hand that intimidating why are
all four defenders together I feel like
Luke Cage and Daredevils I'll handle
this on their own and I mean you pointed
it out look I would have I would have
thought that it would have been more
compelling the way Alexander and then
how she turns I would have been more
interesting but look hey I also thought
- what would have been more interesting
not only the hand with what happened
with the city collapsing I thought they
were going after dragons are going after
like becoming super-powered beings in
their galley I thought it was gonna be
something like oh that's a something
huge and I just did again it is very
threatening the city collapsing on
itself it's just you never felt the
station of the calamity of the situation
like of the city's gonna fall like okay
I mean that felt very I guess like it's
more like age of Ultron when you're
seeing this it's gonna fall
you know the whole movie is gonna fall
in like the whole like you're feeling
the visual imagery of the impact they're
like if that thing Falls like everyone's
gonna die and I get it they don't have
the budget to compete with that but
it's just the situation they concocted
for all the defenders to come together
it's like can we get a little better of
a more menacing
you know version of what's gonna happen
to this idea I get it all the ass for
because I feel like my main issue with
this show and I feel like a lot of my
issue that I'm about to point out a lot
of that not all of it but I feel like a
lot of it could probably disappear with
a second viewing is the structure and
the tone of this show
because the structure of this show kind
of makes everything feel all over the
place it's like one might come in and
say well no Greg and Andrew and there
they are saying New York City is gonna
collapse but you're not really fully
thinking about that that's not really at
the forefront of your mind it's in so
many different directions and not
everything is fleshed out and and it's
such a clever concrete way that I kind
of feel like they were all over the
place at times with its tone yes
especially is because I feel like the
first two episodes here's how I would
judge the show the first two episodes
all set up and the set up really took
its time and felt a little dull the
first time but by the time I got to
episode three I was like okay I get
exactly what they were doing and they
were just doing a lot of build-up and
I'm grateful for it three four five and
six it's it's defenders versus in the
hand and we got to figure out what they
want to do with iron fist
then Alexandra dies and the horse show
[ __ ] changes and it becomes like this
90s cheesy kind of territory and it was
that final two episodes in terms of
structure that really it was the final
two episodes that I felt kind of ruined
a lot of the experience for me because
they don't even wrap up a lot of things
they set up a lot in the first two
episodes with personal investments luke
cage's involved because of this kid from
Harlem jessica jones is involved because
she fell architect yeah because of the
architect and she feels for the
architects wife and daughter and then
when the time the show wraps up we don't
even get a like what the hell is Luke
cages are taking all this Luke Cage has
no arc here he's just yeah I'm back in
Harlem and like nothing with the kid or
the mom that he goes in business and has
a really heartfelt yeah nothing with
Jessica Jones and the
and daughter you're right with that but
I did like her arc in regards to just
start restarting aliasing yeah yeah I
got her back into Batman I gave it
credit for that in the beginning of this
review I made sure to also point that I
did appreciate that arc but no you you
make a good point I think you make also
a good point in regards to a second
viewing on the tonal inconsistencies
here and there but the second time it
really didn't bother me as much because
again you know what to expect you know
what you're getting in the first two
episodes that are gonna you know yeah to
connect you to the next did it change
your experience with the last two
episodes as I feel like you would have
changed my experience with the first
tube I wouldn't change I still I still
had like I said I still had problems
with Alexandra's death how that was all
handled I think again if you would have
just kept her around for episode seven
and eight rejuvenator done that it would
have again fixed my experience with
seven and eight and felt the calamity
the situation it doesn't fix those
moments for me but and one other thing I
got to mention we kind of were tired of
talking about flaws re-watching I really
noticed this Jessica Jones when they're
escaping Elektra throws one of the sighs
to stop the elevator Jessica Jones then
holds it and I think Danny's like holy
or something yeah and they start
climbing but then Jessica lets go of the
elevator which room did that elevator
come from comes from the room were mad
yeah and a lecturer fighting in there's
no drops like I was waiting like five
minutes like did that elevator not drive
did drop 20 minutes ago or not it was
below it's kind of like she wrote like
in Batman 89 when Joker
you know uses the acid to take down the
Bell and it stops the police from coming
in it's like if he would have done the
acid with the Bell and then it never
dropped and the police never got in it's
like wasn't it supposed to drive I'm
like okay so the I know they had budget
restraints but did anyone not notice
that in the editing like the Bell or the
elevator has not dropped yeah I don't
know but no that's a good point I feel
like I already said it in my like solo
reviews for me episodes it just felt
like the last episode especially really
bothered me with the way how it was
handled it felt like you know by the
time I mean that not last of us was
called the defenders and then by the
time they're underground and they're all
assembling and they do the cool tracking
shot and hang Amash The Avengers
you know March to the Avenger
and also you said the lens light it
light it up yeah there might be a Hulk
smash it reminded me of that and I felt
like they were trying to make us feel I
felt like I could see what they're going
for they want us to feel superhero time
that's just and I'm like I didn't feel
like they got there organically I felt
like we kind of rushed to get to this
feeling and I don't feel it because I
felt rushed to get here this these solo
shows the strength of it is that they're
so opposite from the Marvel movie is
rated R version their Marvel's in the
dark and gritty they can get sexual they
can get closer you know their way to say
are you saying when Wilson fists
decapitate that maybe you know I wanna
make a little sign now you said well
suppose I want to harp on this too much
because I want to finish my point here
but what I feel like okay you gave us
Wilson Fisk who was a great business
villain kind of like Alexandria if you
gave us someone like kilgrave if you
gave us a Wilson Fisk and kilgrave life
together a business person a Lex Luthor
type or Wilson Fisk type and then
someone with super powers that can match
Luke Cage because that's what many
kilgrave intimidated seek you control
Luke Cage yeah you can tell them then
dude like if you had Wilson fisting kill
Graham as the villains that would have
been a way more interest now yeah it
would have had all them and even didn't
make the mistake of killing cottonmouth
or kill Graham and had it all for them
they're like how are the defenders yeah
Pete that would've gave the feeling of
like why and then when they defeat them
it's like that was so like the way they
defeat the hand it's like oh they just
use their typical martial arts moves
they were just doing yeah but no if you
if you think about if they would have
had those four villains Plus Alexandra
you still get the hand in there because
it's a it's a part of of Alex's she's
the same finger they establish that
Wilson Fisk his works would they hated
madam young I'm so was a missed
opportunity really could have done that
would and again maybe you need to add
another episode or two to make it happen
or whatever and obviously like we said
just make someone in the ham with with
super here super human abilities that
are
to make it be like well it's like when
Luke Cage is going through these guys
I'm like these guys will send chance
again they usually establish that with
Elektra as the black saying I did notice
more in the second beauty she did one
person against four was knocking them
around a good few times and even when
she killed stick she did knock them all
out other than iron fist it was already
tied up so they I get where they were
coming from but again you want to feel
multiple then rather just one singular
character and with those four villains I
would have been so it's not only
compelling and dramatic it just would
have been more interesting with these
four characters and and again you said
it best it would have just been beyond
satisfying if they end clever when they
beat them like because you can't imagine
a scenario where that even as powerful
as the defenders beating those four and
one thing I would have liked to that I
wish the show gave us and I thought they
were gonna do it because you know how
the first couple episodes they hop back
and forth in their solo stories yes and
then you could see the different tint in
the cinematography Daredevils is red
luke cage's yellow you know you know
talking about her purple and then this
is green yeah so I loved that and then
when all the defenders got together they
didn't try to have a specific look for
the show that that's something I felt
was missing for was a distinct
cinematography appeal to it as well and
I was like come on man you tease us with
the first two episodes with like oh I
like give us a cool color blend or
something to have a really distinct
visual appeal there no I agree and in
regards to camerawork too after we had
just seen Terminator 2 Judgment Day and
seeing what James Cameron and Adam
Greenberg did with the cinematography
and that I know it's not fair to compare
that's $100,000,000 to a Marvel Netflix
show of course on I'm just talking
cinematography wise when you watch the
handheld stuff with James and Adam were
able to do and then then you watch some
of the handheld stuff here it's it can
be a little intoxicating and just like
how the cameras rolling and moving it's
just I just a month again not comparing
I just wished a cinematographers and
directors they would watch movies like
Terminator 2 and other movies of that
nature where you can see that blend of
of handheld and and that visual look
like it's it's a part of the director
and a part of what they're going for and
it just it kind of makes you get more is
cinematically invested in what you're
watching yeah I would I agree with you I
would have visually impression
my biggest thing was on some of the
there were some episodes where the
camera work was done tremendously and I
really appreciate like going in air
vents doing other shots and stuff like
that there were some really clever shots
when Jessica opens a cupboard and you
see it from from the coverage yeah there
were definitely some really cool
interesting shots it's just I had a lot
of problem with scenes where people are
standing around the cameras all shaking
and doing that I don't mind that in
moments with action or moments of when
the characters are moving because then
you feel more part of the action it's
when characters are standing around
doing nothing and then the camera
shaking it just it makes me feel very
dizzy and it me personally it just gets
me really intoxicated I just don't
appreciate this but I have like exact
opposite feelings I feel like that part
of the problem the action that bothered
me other than its tracking shot and even
in the hallway fight they had some
pretty cool shots in the hallway fight
was a lot of times the action was like
so heavily edited and so heavily
handheld that I was like what the [ __ ]
is going on in this fight and then I
don't mind it within the scenes but I
can also see how that bothers someone
yeah I can definitely see what you're
saying I don't mind in action scenes if
you can see clearly what's going on
there's a way to do it yeah devil season
one decibel yes yeah well no so they've
got the fight the stunt guy in the fight
choreographers for Winter Soldier doing
that so you can't tell because the fight
choreography and Winter Soldier and
Civil War some of the best I've ever
seen
amazing movies because like I remember
the fight would Nobu and daredevil and
seize that one great that's hand held
that's funny you can still see what's
going on it's still a very intense and
gripping tonight I wish they would
rewatch that that's Maxine just you know
actually actually earlier I just
re-watched the hallway fight not the
daredevil season one one that won in
season two when Punishers in the
elevator right and I'm like man there's
nothing in defenders that matches
daredevil season 2 or Punisher is taking
out all the people in the prison oh yeah
yeah tracking show in the handheld the
way it's done like once I wanted to feel
some of those moments I felt like the
last two episodes lost a lot of its grit
lost a lot of what makes these shows so
appealing and they started it really
feels like they were rushing it because
they only had eight episodes left like I
feel like that sixth episode twist could
have worked if they had if they had one
or two more episodes
I think maybe not a full 13 but one or
two more episodes allow it to flesh it
out give time for Matt to grieve over
six death I mean [ __ ] oh I felt like oh
nothing cared when they weren't grief
when Ben Urich dies in season one we get
like a hole up so dedicated agreement
over with on your which I'm happy about
but yeah Ben Urich more importance no no
not in terms of like the relationship
with the main protagonist no you don't
and another thing I felt like yeah I
really feel like a couple more episodes
would have allowed them to like give a
full conclusion on Luke Cage full
conclusion on jessica jones and also the
other thing too was there was a thing
that i felt like they were gonna tap
into and this is why i feel like the
whole setting up iron fist
you know posing as daredevil thing a
little forced I get it's with the comics
would have felt a little forced here
because there's a scene where stick is
talking to Matt about how matt has to be
the real leader and they were hinting at
that in moments then Matt's becoming the
real leader and it's there are scenes
where it's like Matt's taking charge hmm
but he never fully gets there and if he
fully got there if Matt fully got to be
like oh he's the leader even iron fist
is like you're the leader of this gang
then I would have really felt Danny ran
bean like I have to take up the mantle
you know that's when I would have felt
it though you're saying I think still
though yeah I agree with what you're
saying I still think the visual imagery
and seeing that shot was was badass and
badass yeah and the trickery of thinking
about it is Matt Murdock yeah with the
red building in the back of his fist
comes up yeah yeah no no I gotta tell
you I was really hoping to see double
iron fist there I thought that was
that's the mobiles Dagon happy yeah once
you get it where are we gonna see the
dragon - you don't think it's gonna
happen I know the budget insurance but I
mean getting back into the into the
finale I agree with you we got to also
mention of course what happens with Matt
where we go into the born-again
storyline from from daredevil Frank
Miller's born-again storyline now what
happens and that is very similar this in
the born-again comics which I'm stealing
from Greg here what happens in that is a
Wilson Fisk aka the kingpin he beats the
[ __ ] out of daredevil Matt Murdock and
he leaves him to drown in a taxicab in
the East River Matt barely escapes he
goes through Hell's Kitchen he gets to
the boxing gymnasium where his father
believed he was Jack Murdock the
nazy amor jack trained at and that's
where sister Maggie his mother finds him
and she nurses him back to health so
it's very similar live the visual
imagery especially when he's sitting on
the bed with the with the bandanna or
what are the beginnings of us and so
these are two of daredevil ends on a
note with Wilson Fisk being like give me
information on that yeah he's gonna find
out who matters yeah and I'm oh and
obviously I'm looking forward to seeing
Wilson Fisk in season 3 the thing I'm
looking most forward to I hope they go
with bull's eye I think that would be
awesome I know they were talking to
Jason Statham in season 2 daredevil that
didn't end up working out but I know
this kind of Mirrors obviously would
happen in the 2003 film daredevil with
bullseye and kingpin worried if they
bring a lecture back then it would be a
little well I mean she's alive most
likely yeah so Bowman we'll see what
happens with that but I do think it is
interesting how they're going with the
born-again storyline I do wonder if
they're gonna go with what happens in
Karen page in that comic cos she has
major drug problems and she even sells
out Matt to the kingpin yeah and I mean
yeah she has a major drug problem that
coming so I wonder if they're gonna tap
into that in season three we do know
that Karen Paige is gonna be in the
Punisher show which comes out in
November so she's clearly gonna go
through some crazy [ __ ] in that that
might you know internally damage her men
mentally so we'll see how that you know
tracks into this cuz obviously she is
feeling pain and loss from what happened
in her mind what she thinks happened to
Matthew Murdock and I got to say I
really appreciated that moment
especially the second viewing were foggy
and and Karen weren't seeing everyone's
all the defenders are coming back and
being with their loved ones and they're
waiting they're waiting they're waiting
I love how the camera just stays there
and then it pans on to foggy into Karen
we see the emotional you know content
that they have because of that they've
lost their friend and it's just I really
felt that a lot more the second time
just again feeling that human depth and
emotion that investment in these
characters you know what I'm not I
believe forward too though what season
three of daredevil is gonna have with
those guys as I already felt like it's
an erisa representative area yeah we
don't want you to be dared oh oh I get
it I get money brought in this
yeah I know but even reveals his true
motives no you knew the city but said
I'm like Oh after all this [ __ ] oh it's
gonna be way more of that in there no
season three I agree with you but from a
plot point my only yeah you know from my
only plot point is they love their
friend they don't want yeah my sense I
mean if you were if you were fighting is
there no I know I feel you could they go
with more interesting things to talk
about and go over then I don't want you
to be daredevil I agree but from I get
why they do I just want them to push the
characters to a point where they can
just accept Matt for who he is
ya know I get there already I agree with
you and I think moments of Claire where
she says to foggy in the last episode
she says you know your friend Matt since
I've known him any time he has his mind
made there's no talking him down like I
think they are getting to that point I
think they they kind of went over that
repetitive nature a little bit to show
like it's alright go ahead do you
remember in season one a daredevil when
foggy is having issues with Matt and
then they have like I think as a second
or last or the last episode when they
decide to work together right where fog
is like alright let's do this and then
like there are times where Matt uses his
skills to hear stuff and fog is like
this is cool
I want that back spider-man homecoming
reference just say no yes and that
reference aspire my homecoming is
reference to a lot of other just yeah I
agree with you I would like to say that
that definitely is more interesting
situations that they can put on
characters and I agree but again if they
don't do if if they do it again in
season 3 where I don't want you to be
daredevil and that's a major drag thing
then I agree with you now we're getting
a little bit repetitive at some point
gotta accept Matt but it bothered me as
much because they didn't go into it like
a crazy amount in their show they did go
into it a few times but again I
understand where they're coming from
they care about their friend and they
love him so much and Karen does want him
to change so she can be the man that she
wants to be with one day so I get where
they're coming from I and and I get why
people can be annoyed and think it's
repetitive I get I get both arguments
and I guess my last thing I point out is
I'm pretty excited for what they're
doing with misty night missing that was
a character I really appreciate in the
Luke Cage show I like what she did here
a lot I kind of like how she became that
you're the cop character that works with
the vigilantes and trust that me but if
it means getting her in trouble
I like that a protic did with her and
even though I thought the whole bakudo
and
winged [ __ ] was also very repetitive I
thought that was like I thought we wrap
this [ __ ] up pretty well in Iron Fist
Season one we don't need more of this
but when they cut off her arm I was like
oh that's probably why they had all this
[ __ ] so we can get to here that was cool
and I'm excited for we're calling we're
calling wing and Missy and I coming
together that's something I'm looking
forward to I agree with you I'm gonna
get into misty night and really quick
one sec before we wrap this up I just
want to mention um one of my other flaws
I'm sure one of you guys can correct me
in the comments I didn't understand in
terms of the resurrection it with the
head when the head gets cut off right
yeah yeah nevermind I go from the misty
night part I agree with everything you
just said about misty night I again I
was already invested with her from Luke
Cage seeing my favorite interactions
obviously whenever her she's helping the
team I love that but my favorite
interactions came towards the end with
her and calling wing again setting up
the daughters of the Dragon I really
appreciate that stuff I like I hope that
they again do I'd like to one day see
that that's spin-off show I think that'd
be fun and entertaining cuz just again
in those those two minutes is that scene
we had with them I found myself really
enjoying what they were talking about I
get the impression that there's a lot of
like everyone's like favorite parts of
iron for season 2 or a Colleen wing so
might they're probably just gonna give
us a lot of daughters of the Dragon yeah
we do know misty Knight is a hundred
percent going to be an iron fist season
two so if they do do versions and
portions of that in I'm going to but
again I need to see that flashback of
how he got the iron fist I want to see
the battle versus shout out the undying
I need an again your babies wanna see
come on I'm not gonna compare it but are
we getting dragons of the nature of Game
of Thrones where that budget is up there
and it looks incredible or are we
getting this budget well it doesn't feel
like you know they have a lot of money
like especially in the climactic battle
and you see they're in one specific area
on the set it's like are we gonna expand
because I'm there's got to be miles of
the dragon fossils it's like we
literally stayed stationary in one
specific area it's like it didn't feel
like the budget constraints are where
you wanted it to be so if we do get to
see Shou Lao I'm hoping that it's gonna
be something visually spectacular one
other mention to we
to talk about with misty night in Herat
in her hospital room with Colin wing if
you notice on the the what is that the
drawing board the chart it says el
Carter that's actually Linda Carter
she's the original night nurse in the
comics she liked Claire's been inspired
by yeah the clarin also too she's she
helps the superheroes she heals them up
she also had a thing with dr. strange
obviously they didn't use that version
in the doctors in the 2016 Scott
Derrickson Doctor Strange film they used
the christine palmer rachel mcadams
version so i don't expect to see that
but i just want to point out that was a
pretty cool event Linda Carter and also
that's obviously the name of the actress
who plays Wonder Woman later so pretty
cool yeah so uh yeah we gave all our
opinions here really quick Andrew just
the one should give a rating out of 10 I
probably give this a like an 8 or 8.5
somewhere around there I still again it
wasn't what I wanted it to be especially
the last two episodes up from episodes 1
to 6 I really found myself enjoying
everything and again there were things
in episode 7 and 8 that I didn't
appreciate enjoy like again the
emotional investment you feel from foggy
and and Karen you know what they feel
towards mad and all that and some of the
arcs we didn't say enough they had
mistakes were the biggest issue what
happened with Alexandra but overall see
episodes 1 through 6
I probably rate those more in the nine
nine and a half range because those ones
on repeat watch I really love those
episodes a lot more but again I thought
this show again had great interactions
had pretty good dialogue between the
characters visual visually wise special
effects wise there were some cool shots
with the iron fist and seeing that
repeat shot from Luke 8 the Madam's yeah
you gotta do some [ __ ] you have to
do some cool things and jessica jones
got to punch her with an oxygen tank it
is pretty funny her and Luca don't
teamwork that was pretty cool I liked
some of the fights were done really well
that won the first fight we got to see
between all of them I I was up and
cheering I wish I would have been around
she with you to see that but I was up
and cheering going crazy the worst a lot
of good stuff in here the were a couple
things I you know I didn't appreciate
but overall I found myself enjoying this
a lot more on second viewing and I still
did appreciate it enjoy it and I found
it entertaining and I still found myself
very invested in these characters
especially a lot more and an ear and I'm
still not where I want to be with him
but a lot
when I was at the end of Iron Fist
season one so I like that we did get an
interesting villain up until the end of
episode six in my opinion and again I
did like all that banter an interaction
between the villains and the conflict
that they had I thought that stuff was
compelling and interesting so like I
said there was a lot of good stuff that
I enjoyed in season one I think your
suggestion of combining all the villains
would have been more compelling and in
tension-filled would have felt villains
that are like yeah yeah just but but
point being there are some things I
could have made it a lot better into
what I want I know you had this show
very hyped up and you were looking for
more forward to it from that perspective
it didn't hit me because I was pretty up
there but if it wasn't fair of me to
hype it up that much but sorry that's
just what I do I found boy out a little
bit but again I really appreciated
episodes 1 through 6 a lot more the
second time through and I think possibly
you would too and maybe some other
people but I do get the criticisms other
people had including myself and even you
like there were some things you even
said here that that you felt a little
negative towards that I didn't fully
agree with but your argument like you
were making good arguments for like
where I understood where you were coming
from that it didn't bother me why that
I'm like I get what bothers you like you
were making good conviction what
bothered you and I feel like I was too
so again I'm not trying to be negative I
let I really enjoyed the show I thought
it was very entertaining it was fun I
think second viewing is a lot better
like I said the human and Iraq are the
interactions the human emotion invest
the the the depth and emotion that you
get is very it gets you a lot more
invested in these characters throughout
the show again and I just appreciated it
and I thought some of the action was
really cool as well in some of the
cinematography was pretty cool too but I
can't wait to see what we got next I
believe it's Punisher his name so I'm
really looking forward to that I still
love these shows again didn't hit me
where I wanted it to but I still really
enjoyed my show and I'd still give it
about an 8 or an 8.5 somewhere on there
so pretty good yeah III agree with a lot
of what you said my ratings definitely
lower or give it like a 6 point 5 or 7
which could still make it fresh from
Iran to Tomatoes that's what counts
that's all that man I definitely drew
more than Iron Fist season 1 and yeah
there's play to appreciate about it it's
just really the last two episodes I
really did am NOT the kind
a lot of the show for me but I think the
first six episodes are pretty damn solid
I think those first six are pretty damn
good episodes and I do feel with the
second viewing even the flaws I found in
the first couple episodes would probably
be vastly improved with a second viewing
and maybe even the last two as well so
yeah it's currently 6.5 or somewhere
just six point five to seven I would
give it but yeah that's just my overall
pain and I just want to say too this is
the last video we're shooting in this
real I know in terms of this set this
office just said hey I'm moving back
into a studio apartment the YouTube ads
are just too bad in place that I've been
used this place as an office of John's
gonna be moving in he's gonna be having
this place to himself the office the
office will be Nia's bedroom now and we
back shooting in the living room so
we're gonna bring back the red couch in
case you guys missed that I signed this
to that couch been gone all year it's
coming back baby it's coming back Andrew
thank you for being here providing your
wonderful insight and knowledge my
friend Greg thank you for having me
please do yourself a favor and follow
Andrew at the movie source channel on
YouTube he clearly knows what he's
talking about he's clearly only one in a
deal from him only when he steals from
me that's what he does best what we do
in Hollywood he's like I'm like the
adviser and he's my trump that's how I
do this so go check out Andrew on the
movie source channel a Gore 7-eleven on
Twitter and Instagram you can subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell and check out our
patreon become a patron eject a day do
it much love to all of you watch I got
or spoke down